in the previous video we started
thinking about things like population
growth rate and how it relates to the
birth rate and the death rate within a
population and we related that to some
of the seemingly complex formulas that
you might see on an AP Biology formula
sheet now we're going to extend that
conversation to discuss some of the
other formulas you might see but to
realize that they really are just
intuition using a little bit of fancy
math notation so just as a little bit of
review we looked at an example where if
in a population the birthrate is 60
bunnies per year we're talking about
bunnies here it's a population of
bunnies and the death rate is 15 bunnies
per year well what's the population
growth rate well in a given year you
would expect 60 bunnies to be born so
that would add to the population and you
would expect 15 bunnies to die so that
would take away from the population for
a net increase of 49 bunnies per year
and to put that in the language of your
AP Biology formula sheet the notation
they use for population growth rate they
use a fancy notation so actually let me
just write it over here they say n is
equal to your population n is equal to
population and then your population
growth rate they use calculus notation
so our change in population / change in
time this is really talking about
something in calculus known as
instantaneous change but we don't have
to get too bogged down with that just
yet but your population growth rate
which you could use this notation for is
equal to your birth rate 60 bunnies per
year and the notation they use for birth
rate is just B they don't use the same
rate notation for that I probably would
have but that's fine I'm just trying to
make you form familiar with what you
might see and then minus the death rate
minus D so this right over here is
something that you would see on that
formula sheet but it makes fairly
intuitive sense now the next idea we're
going to think about is something known
as a per capita growth rate of
population let me write it out in words
first so here we're going to think about
a per capita growth rate
or population growth rate per capita
population growth rate now per capita
means you could view it as a on average
per individual what is the average
growth rate per individual what is that
going to be pause this video and try to
think about it well one way you could
think about it it's the total population
growth rate divided by the population
divided by the number of people there
are so it's going to be our population
growth rate growth rate divided by
divided by our population population now
let's say that we have a population of
300 bunnies so actually let's make the
math a little bit simpler let's say we
have a population of 450 bunnies so what
is going to be our per capita populate
per capita population growth rate pause
this video and try to figure that out
well if we have a population of 450
bunnies 450 bunnies
our population growth rate per the
number of people we are a number of
bunnies I should say is going to be
equal to our population growth rate is
45 bunnies bunnies per year and that's
going to be for every 450 bunnies 450
bunnies which will get us to 45 divided
by 450 is 0.1 and then the unit's
bunnies cancel with bunnies so it's 0.1
per year
now why is per capita population growth
rate interesting well it tells us just
how likely and in most populations you
need at least a male and a female in
order to reproduce but there are some
organisms that can just split and and
reproduce asexually but it tells us on
average per individual that organism per
individual organism how much are they
are they going to grow per year so it
gives you a sense of that now connecting
it to the notation that you might see on
an AP Biology formula sheet it would
look like this the
capita population growth rate is usually
denoted by the lowercase letter R and
then they would say that that is going
to be equal to our population growth
rate which we've already seen that
notation the rate of change of our
population with respect to time DN DT
divided by our population divided by our
population now we can algebraically
manipulate this a little bit to get
another expression we could multiply
both sides times our uppercase n times
our population and we're going to get DN
DT is equal to n times R or R times n
let me rewrite it we could rewrite this
as DN DT is equal to our per capita
population growth rate times our
population now this once again makes
sense if you say okay this is how many
people how many individuals I have and
if in a given year they grow by this
much on average well if you multiply the
two you'll know how much the whole
population has grown so if we didn't
know these numbers and someone said hey
watch it we could think about this let's
think about now a population of a
thousand bunnies so if n was equal to
1000 now let's say they're the same type
of bunnies that have the same
probability of reproducing and the same
likelihood so we know that r is equal to
0.1 per year for this population of
bunnies what is going to be our
population growth rate pause this video
and try to figure that out well in this
situation DN DT is going to be our per
capita population growth rate so it's
going to be 0.1 per year times our
population times 1000 bunnies bunnies
I'll keep my unit's here bunnies and so
this is going to be equal to 1 1000
times 1/10 is 100 where in that color
it's 100 bunnies bunnies
per year so hopefully you're getting an
appreciation for why these types of
formulas which are fairly
straightforward they're using just a
fancy notation are useful now this is
also an interesting thing to look at
because even though that this is in
fancy calculus notation and they're
saying that our rate of change of
population is equal to R times our
population this is actually a
differential equation if you were to
think about what this population the
type of population this would describe
this would actually be a population
that's just that's growing exponentially
so this is often known as an exponential
growth equation let me write that down X
potential exponential growth and in
other in your math classes in your
calculus classes or even in your
precalculus classes you will study
exponential growth in a biology class
you're really just thinking about how to
manipulate this a little bit but just to
give you a little sense of what's going
on with exponential growth if you have a
population of bunnies with this type of
exponential growth what is happening
here this is time and this is your
population so you're going to have some
starting population here and it's just
going to grow exponentially and the
higher the R is the steeper this
exponential growth curve is going to be
but this describes how populations can
grow if they are not constrained by the
environment in any way they have just as
much land as much water and as much food
as they need eventually the bunnies will
fill the surface of the earth and the
universe now obviously we know that that
is not a realistic situation that any
ecosystem has some natural carrying
capacity there's only so much food
there's only so much land at some point
there's just going to be bunnies falling
from trees and and it's going to be easy
for prep much easier for predators to
get them and all these other things and
we will discuss that in the next video
how do we how do we adapt the
exponential growth equation right over
here to factor it a little bit more of a
real-world situation where at some
population you're going to be getting
you're going to be hitting up against
the carrying capacity of the environment